i'm a huge fan of john mullaney's as as
as i think we all are but
you do uh a great john mulaney
impression i think
for him i was just kind of i think i
watched his
stand-ups a few specials and i was
thinking of like he always goes i've
noticed
when i wear my pants sometimes i do have
ants in my pants
and that's a saying but it's true to my
life
it's always saying like i noticed
something uh
an observation and then uh
he's got kind of an old fashioned uh
sort of diction and i mean he could be
in vaudeville it could be 1922 when he
has john mullaney
you know they saw it on on the snl at
home
um he was in the master class sketch
where he's a master
at at putting on suits putting together
your tie
and your butt and look like you're going
to your first holy communion
and so he saw it and he really liked it
and i
noticed he does a certain thing when
he's walking goes
[Music]
you know you know what one of the
impressions that
you do i'm just talking about how you'll
pick an unusual target
the little rascals the little rascals is
something that i grew up watching and
it's from the 1930s but they would show
it a lot on local television when i was
a kid
that's how i know it i didn't even know
that someone your age would be aware of
the little rascals we would rent the
little rascals vhs the classics oh good
okay but the past few months my mom
just let me borrow her little rascal
dvds and she said give them back
because these are my favorite i'm not
going to keep them
no yeah and so you learned you started
watching those and i'm told you do a
little rascal's impression or an
impression of a little
of the little rascals well because i i
was trying to watch
little rascals and i couldn't even get
through an episode i don't know what
they're saying
you can't hear it it's so crinkly and
old you know
they're just like nothing he's got his
heartbeat
how do you want his phone
no hamburger
that's all i can hear so yeah that's
pretty much all it is and also
long takes they'll do like they'll be
visuals of like spanky looking
or alfalfa looking at something or
somebody a buck we i know they'll just
be looking at something and they'll be
like
and the camera will be on them way too
long and you think
they just had more time in the 19th
you know comedy but it's like this and
back then
someone would do something funny and
they'd cut to someone else going
yeah you're like what you just had more
time during the depression
wasn't film expensive then